- C'est la fête partout
au Québec. Dans les villes,
les quartiers, on met
en musique, en mot, en décor
du peuple québécois.
♪ On swing la bacaisse
dans le fond du COVID! ♪
♪ On fête la Saint-Jean! ♪
nationale en raison de
mie, les Québécois
savourent la liberté.
- Mais c'est un bonheurue
comme ça librement,
puis c'est agréable.
- Et écouter de la musique
dans la rue, faire la fêteais fa
dans sa vie. Elle est née
pendant la pandémie. Donc, ça
fait du bien, on est contents.
- Les gens, se ret, bien, c', b!
♪ J'ai défait mesdéfait mesdéfar
les laisser voler au vent ♪uébes
plusieurs autres villes,
des artistes ont pris d'assaut
les scènes éphémères.
- ÊtrLes Québécois ensemble,
c'est beau. Juste tout le monde
est gentil, tu sais.
- Et l'on doit en être fier,
en visite à Charlemagne
dans sa circonscription.
- Hé! tu me fais un cadeau,
à part de ça!ture du frture du s
en Amérique mérite qu'on
la célèbre, elle dont l'avenir
est menacé.
FRANÇministre du Québec
- Cette nation-là, qui a survécu
400 ans, il faut qu'elle
continue de survivre.
le français. Oui, de se battre
contre le multiculturalisme,
pas parce qu'on est contre
les autres, là, parce qu'on est
mais il y a un défi
d'intégration au français.
erchères, une statue
à l'effigie d'un des plus
illustres indépendantistes,
Bernard Landry, est inaugurée.
PAUL ST-PAUL ST-PAUL ST-PAUL ST,
chef, Parti québécois
- Si tout le monde au Québectabe
et têtu que Bernard Landry,
on aurait la certitude que
l'indépendance va se faire.
certains, mais à court terme,
les Québécois veulent fêter.
le méchoui, le feu de joie,
la bière qu'il me manque
dans les mains!
soyez pasoyez pasoyez pasoyez p.
Je ne suis pas un des premiers
partis ici!
- Bonne Saint-Jean!
Paquette-Comeau,
Radio-Canada, Mo